hello Turkey's president has vowed to
keep fighting in Syria until all his
country's goals have been met reject ie
Berta Juan is shrugging off
international pressure for an immediate
ceasefire and the battle on the ground
goes on the town of frosted iron is on
the frontline gunfire and heavy
artillery have been heard right across
the city as Turkish and Kurdish forces
fight for control now diplomatic efforts
are also intensifying the US vice
president Mike Pence and the secretary
state Mike Pompeo will travel to Turkey
to push for a ceasefire they come armed
with president Trump's threat of more
sanctions if they're ignored but that's
unlikely to sway presidents Iran in an
address to his AK party he said he won't
be influenced by foreign intimidation
we are Nicky take to Canada to where our
chief Katie today all the suggestions
and threats we're not going to accept I
think that has been clear from the start
by our attitude we want this terror
organization removed from our borders
when the zone from manbij to the Iraqi
border when we established this 35
kilometers deep safe zone this operation
will end but up until breaching this
point no power can stop us well
Irwin's also defended the operation
against critics who say civilians are in
the line of fire he says Turkey has
never and will never commit a civilian
massacre severe damage or mixtures
others haven't borne illness and even
death if you want to see civilian
casualties look at the streets of
Palestine where Muslims are killed in
the streets if you want to see civilian
massacres look at the terror
organization who killed our women our
elderly our children they were killed by
them in the last 40 years if you want to
see civilian massacres look in the
mirror and look at history and look at
all the blood of the innocents in your
own hand Turkey can never be accused
meanwhile the UN special envoy for Syria
is in Damascus and he's calling for an
immediate end to the Turkish operation
and a meetings been called at the UN to
discuss Syria our diplomatic editor
James bass will tell us more about that
shortly while our White House
correspondent Kimberly halket is
standing by in Washington first we bring
in zina hooded who's in actually that's
on the turkey-syria border with a
defiant message Dana from Iran has
the Turkish military operation playing
out on the ground right now well it
hasn't been easy it's now entering its
second week fierce combat in rasulina
that is a border town the Kurdish led
Syrian democratic forces mounting a
fierce defense using tunnels using
trenches so it's not an easy fight
Andres Alain may be a small border town
but it is key in Turkey's plans to
create a safe zone along the border east
of the Euphrates because wrastlin should
be part of this safe zone so fierce
combat on the ground and Russia Russia
stepping in the United States has left
the area but Russia making clear who is
calling the shots they have deployed
their military police on frontlines
laying claim to a number of areas
members for example a key town in the
northern countryside of Aleppo which
Turkey also wanted to capture it wanted
it's a local Syrian allies to take
control of members from the Syrian
Syrian Kurdish armed group the YPG which
makes up the backbone of the SDF and now
it has it's not as no longer able to
advance towards the city because of the
deployment of Russian troops so on the
ground it is facing resistance and like
you mentioned diplomatic pressure the
greatest crisis in decades with its NATO
ally the United States Oregon telling
the u.s. no I am NOT interested in a
ceasefire I'm not interested in
negotiations but most importantly
serious different differences with
Russia a country that it is a partner
with in Syria it should be working
together with Syria Russia making it
clear it's not happy with the Turkish
intervention in Syria it is not happy
with turkeys military presence in Syria
altogether so Russia really putting a
lot of pressure on Turkey and our Dogon
yesterday calling the Russian President
Putin Putin inviting Oregon but they
still we still don't know the date of
that meeting ok Zana Haddad with an
update from our chocolate thank you well
speaking before he heads to Turkey the
US Secretary of State Mike Juan Payoh
has made it clear that he'll be pushing
for an end to the offensive we have
every expectation that we will meet with
president air21
you know and it's and it's important
Maria wouldn't have this conversation
with him directly president felt it was
important that we do this at the most
senior levels of the United States
government to speak to him face to face
he needs to stop it needs to stop the
incursion into Syria this is a
complicated matter with lots of states
at play let's break this down with
Kimberly Calicut she's joining us from
Washington so what are we to make of the
president sending such a high-level
delegation to Turkey Kimberly well the
US president is very clear that he wants
to send a message and essentially that
message is that the United States is
looking for an immediate ceasefire and
negotiated settlements so this is what
the hope is that this delegation
expected to leave Washington about 22
GMT ahead over to meet for the US
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo saying
there of what they expect to be a
face-to-face meeting with the Turkish
leader is to try and achieve these goals
now we should point out in just the last
hour so the US president has been
speaking about the situation from The
Oval Office we expect that this take
playback will be coming in soon but we
are starting to get some early notes
from it and the US president is once
again defending his decision to move
aside troops in order for Turkey to make
its way in in terms of this military
operation he's defending this decision
saying if Turkey goes into Syria it is
between Turkey and Syria it's not our
problem meaning the United States but
clearly there is a feeling that it is
the United States problem or this
high-level delegation would not be being
sent the other thing coming out of this
meeting with the Italian president at
the Oval Office is this statement from
the US President Donald Trump
essentially saying the Kurds are no
angels and this is getting a lot of
traction given there is a real feeling
in the United States that this decision
by the United States to pull back troops
has betrayed the Kurds the fact that the
the Kurds who lost 11,000 people
fighting alongside US troops and in the
effort to defeat ISIL that the United
States has just turned its back on these
fighters and the US president sort of
doubling down on that insult by saying
the Kurds are
Oh angels so these are the latest
statements come into the White House as
I said we expect that not only will we
see that tape playback soon we also
expect the US president to have more to
say on this when he has a joint presser
with the Italian president the coming
hours and then later about 19:00 GMT at
the White House the US president will be
meeting with congressional leaders also
not happy with his Syria's Turkey
strategy that are putting together their
own legislation right now to essentially
try and undo the president's moves all
right so a lot going on over there a
Kimberley healthcare for the time being
thank you for that update let's bring in
our diplomatic editor James BAE's
joining us from the United Nations and
not the first time James that European
members of the Security Council have
requested a meeting on what's taking
place in Northeast Syria what do we
expect to happen yes well we believe
that meeting is about to get underway in
the next few minutes in fact let's just
show you the picture over here that is
actually the doorway into the Security
Council where the closed meeting will be
taking place what they'll be doing is
having a meeting about Western Sahara
that meeting we understand has just come
to an end or is about to come to an end
and then they're moving on to the agenda
item about Syria and what's going on in
Northeast Syria and we've just seen the
two UN briefers come in he'll be
briefing the Security Council in that
closed meeting the head of humanitarian
affairs mark low [ __ ] and Khalid kyani
who's the assistant secretary-general
for political affairs they will be
briefing the Security Council on the
current situation we've seen a few
ambassadors around here outside the
meeting while they were discussing
Western Sahara interesting citing a
short time ago I saw the Turkish
ambassador here although he's now left
the area ahead of this closed meeting
which was called by European members of
the Security Council since we last spoke
the situation has not improved quite the
country the number of IDPs the number of
people needing humanitarian aids
the number of people who are fleeing
this area reaches 200,000 and the
Unitarian situation justice is very very
worrying we are still very concerned
about the all the implications of this
offensive amana terian obviously a lot
of people on the run and another concern
is also about - you know in possible
resurgence the fact that apparently some
prisoners have been able to escape so
all this is is absolutely very
concerning and so that's why the EU
members of the council have called for
this meeting - because things are really
evolving very rapidly on the ground as
you know some interesting developments
just as this meeting moves behind closed
doors from Western Sahara to Syria and
that's the u.s. Ambassador Kelly craft
has actually left the area and headed
away whether that's for some discussions
quietly with some of her colleagues and
she'll be returning or whether she's not
saying staying for the Syria
agenda item isn't clear certainly when
they discussed this last week she came
out and made a statement at the end to
reporters taking no questions what the
Europeans are hoping is that they can
get a unified statement from the
Security Council even if it's a pretty
brief one expressing concern I'm told
that that is something they are hoping
for but not necessarily expecting and if
they don't get that we believe what's
most likely is that we'll see the
European ambassadors come to the podium
here themselves and make their own
statement okay James will cross to you a
little later thank you for that update
from the United Nations let's talk to
Baron ko Glu he's an assistant professor
of world history at the American
University to Iraq he's joining us from
Ankara thanks very much for your time
with us on the al Jazeera news hour
let's first talk about the US delegation
that's headed to Ankara in a couple of
hours time they're pushing for a
negotiated ceasefire that's what we're
being told but her Dewan according to
what he's saying is in no mood to
negotiate so to what extent do you
expect to see some sort of agreement or
some sort of under
standing between the two sides when they
meet thank you for thank you very much
for having me on the show I believe from
the Turkish perspective there are two
things either President and Diwan and
president Trump agreed on what the
nature of the Turkish operation into
Syria would be or both men prefer sort
of off-the-cuff rather casual
conversations over more formal
commitments and agreed actually that the
Turkish operation will turn out to be
this way
but facing domestic backlash President
Trump decided to second-guess himself
and started imposing sanctions on Turkey
and as a result of that president had
gone of course is responding to a
domestic audience a domestic expectation
that that he believes would would
respond more positively to an operation
in northern Syria against YPG SDF forces
which are known to be allied with with
the Kurdistan Workers Party got a group
that has been fighting the Turkish
government's since 1984 and what it's
not going to be easy for president I
don't want to stop the offensive when he
has committed himself so much but I
believe that there will be modalities
and possibility of working something out
with the Trump administration given the
the very high-level nature of the
delegation that is about to arrive in in
Ankara what do you make of the
international pressure that seems to be
piling up on president Erdogan as well
as the threat of more US sanctions I
believe at the heart of that problem
lies a very serious misunderstanding on
Turkey's part on the one hand because
because of turkeys problems with the PKK
Turkey's own inability to resolve its
Kurdish question sir the success of
Turkish government's with very different
ideological viewpoints and
social and political bases have
continued to see the PKK as an
existential threat for Turkey after the
Syrian civil war especially with the
rise of the of the PYD and its armed
groups the the YPG which evolved into
the Syrian democratic forces the SDF
turkey has insisted on the international
arena that it does not consider PKK as
fundamentally different than Isis this
argument has not hold water in the
international community basically
everyone you talk to who follows the
Syrian civil war sees the the YPG forces
as as the anti-isis and a very effective
as a very effective force that has
played a critical role in defeating Isis
now says international pressure
continues to pile on Ankara my question
to you is is it going to have any impact
on president Erdogan and the trajectory
of the military operation I would be
lying to you if I said I knew the answer
to that question but I I can say this
much Turkish president Antoine is
someone who has always acted in his best
political interests and currently it is
not in his best political interest to
risk further sanctions destabilize his
country's economy further and then and
then you know risk his own policy
domestic political standing so I do
expect him to perhaps declare some sort
of victory because the Turkish military
has made some headway in northern Syria
and then start talking with Turkey's
Western partners with the United States
and the European Union okay we'll leave
it there Baron Caio Louie thank you very
much for speaking to us from Ankara